In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 4 on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Yerothios, Bishop of Athens.
On the 4th of the month, we celebrate the memory of Saint Yerothios, Bishop of Athens.
Saint Yerothios, like St. Dionysius, was one of the nine member court of the Ariopagus,
and, with him, one of the few who converted when Saint Paul came to preach in Athens.
On the departure of the Apostle, Yerothios became the first bishop there, and undertook
to initiate Dionysius into the knowledge of the mysteries that God had opened to the contemplation
of his illumined intellect.
He too was transported upon the clouds with the Apostles and Hierarchs to be present at
the entombment of the Mother of God, where immersed in contemplation he intoned divinely inspired
canticles with ecstatic fervor.
The fruits of his contemplation are recorded fragmentarily in the works of his disciple Dionysius.
For he himself made no record of what he received from God.
Faithful in his life and teachings, Saint Yerothios entered into the joy of the Lord, leaving
Dionysius as his successor.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.